hello everyone thank you for well
welcome my name is Elena Neves scientist
at create Swiss I work in a financial
crime compliance team and this talk is
about using isolation forest for anomaly
detection with application to you AM L
AM L stands for antimony wondering can I
have a quick show of hands of who in the
audience works with in financial crime
compliance or otherwise in the in this
area okay that's good so in this talk I
will briefly introduce what is anomaly
detection and what kind of methods are
used we'll look at the application of
anomaly detection to banking so Walker
will cover the three most often used
areas then we'll talk about specifically
for AML if supervised purses and
supervised methods are applicable and
then we'll look at the isolation forests
so we'll step away from the topic of AML
and look at the actual algorithm I'll
describe police resolution first I will
describe how it's implemented the
Sackett learn and we'll compare
performance on the public data set key
to carp 99 most of you probably have
used that before and will compare the
performance to a local I'd laugh actor
then we'll move to isolation force
performance on a synthetic data set that
has been put together specifically with
a few antimony ml red flags embedded in
it and then we'll conclude here's a
quick disclaimer for you to read okay so
what is an anomaly
anomaly is a data point of interest in
in this case it's something that stands
out it's it's an unusual an unusual data
point when a data generating process
behaves and usually it results in an
anomaly anomaly as an anomaly detection
as a topic is a well researched subject
there is a lot of publications out there
in basta testicle and data science the
real challenge for us who practice data
science is to essentially define
construct the right data model for the
subject at hand to separate outliers
from noise and from from the actual
normal data what kind of methods are
used well the methods are broadly
speaking fall into three categories the
density based methods the distance based
methods or parametric you probably used
most of these before the density based
and the distance based they fall into
the spacial proximity type of algorithms
and the examples here are DBC and vocal
a factor K nearest neighbor k-means or
something like a distance to a
regression hip of languages in
regression the parametric passes they
would usually assume some sort of form
to your data so assuming that when
you're working with so what you have
observed so far is normal and models
like garden mixture model or single
classes Williams I use there of course
there are other methods which are not
kind of machine learning methods like
z-score which will assume normality and
many more in terms of application to
banking so many of you probably have
heard of anomaly detection is used in
credit card for detection that's a very
very well-known area where it's used
other other areas such as market abuse
and private banking so much taboos by
clients Oh market abused by both clients
and traders in investment banking I'm
highlighting the ml as the money
laundering as a subject of detection for
all three retail private and
Bank and what is important to understand
is that the the way manual wandering is
done using these three types of banks is
actually different and therefore
different methods of detection and
different types of red flags exist in in
in these banking types so here if you
learn one thing from this talk this
should be the one so another point to be
aware of is that also mate is money
learning detection is very it's actually
an inherently different problem from
optimizing detection tradecraft cray-pas
forward or automatic detection of market
abuse and why is it so well in credit
card fraud we often well we have a
luxury of actually having data when we
have true positive cases or labels and
why because often customers worksheet
tell us if certain transaction wasn't
actually done by them it market abuse
it's slightly hard but still you have
you have a signal in the data so for
example the P&L positive P&L or huge
changes in piano or huge changes in the
price move can be used as a
self-revealing class in case of
automatic money laundering detection
it's much harder because most of the
times especially from the from the
banking perspective from the banks we
don't really have any data that can be
used as a true positive set of cases or
labels what banks do they if they
suspect money laundering they will file
a star to the National Crime Agency and
often it may actually never hear back
from them or if they do here it takes
years so it's not really practical
so for detecting money laundering for
for banking we're pretty much left with
just unsupervised methods so why is it
difficult
well the royalty papers they're actually
quite well described why is it difficult
but of course there is severe class
imbalance this is an outlier detection
problem
what we also deal with Steve Mira class
overlap what that means is that
money-laundering is is when it comes
from a single stream of financial
transactions actually be mixed with with
normal normal activity so what criminals
do they will use front companies
sometimes banks and it makes it much
harder to detect another thing that we
have to deal with is called concept
drift so how money is laundered even by
the same criminal organization changes
over time and of course there is our
certainty around the day tomorrow
so if you choose to use your suspicious
activity report as an indication for
what what whether certain transaction of
such transactions were actually money
laundering then you have a lot of
uncertainty as Angelus so you have a
picture of a candle in the dark most of
the time there is actually no candle
either
so let's step aside from the problem of
money laundering and let's look at the
isolation forest isolation forest is an
ensemble regressor and it is different
from other types of distance or density
based method is that it doesn't profile
normal cases and it doesn't calculate
distances foreign-based distances for
the food item instead what it does it
essentially tries to separate away data
points or explain away anomalies from
normal normal data points underneath it
is building extremely randomized
decision tree and it uses that as a base
estimator isolation forest why is so
good for anomaly detection well because
of campus work post as a supervisor or
an unsupervised classifier it calculates
an anomalous score which is 2 to the
power of minus a ratio of expected
number of edges in the trees for in the
trees in the forest for particular data
point normalized by a constant in the
supervised setting you are going to use
a threshold which is a contamination
ratio to to create a binary
classification problem in the if you can
actually use use it without the
threshold and turn it into a soft
classifier so as the number of edges the
average number of edges in the trees
goes to zero the higher is the anomaly
score so the reason is that actually
anomalous data points they are easier to
explain away from normal data points the
the model isolation force was introduced
in 2008 and became available in
scikit-learn in 2016 so in the previous
version to the current one it extends
the booster activity regressor and it's
possible to use it as both with and
without replacement by default is
without and it's as I said already it's
based estimator is the extremal random
strain regret sir so both the attribute
to split and the displease value will be
chosen randomly this allows you to
overcome building very greedy trees in
practice in the implementation circuit
lien it will return a value of 0.5 minus
the anomalous score so smaller scores or
negative scores will be indicative to
two anomalies so let's take a look at
the performance of this this classifier
on a public dataset kgt up 99 we're
going to quickly switch to
hopefully you can see
so I'm going to use schizocarp 99 and
this will be downloaded from the secular
datasets module and there are a few
options for downloading this modulus let
me just briefly scroll through the
helper methods and about the datasets so
we'll use SI + SF dataset sa has only
four four attributes and herself has 41
the kg Cup 1994 so don't know contains
loads of offline intrusion detection
system it's been around for quite a
while
the SF anomaly rate in this case is 0.5%
so I point 5 percent of data points will
contain actual attempts of hacking
attempts and I say I'm only loading 10%
of the data and here the anomaly rate is
higher it's three point four percent so
we're going to perform some
pre-processing so what we're going to do
is we're going to save all of these all
of the attacks and turn them into one
class and everything which is not an
attack will be probably a negative class
only states a positive class and for the
sake of local at live factor I've also
normalized the data and fields that are
not numeric fields have been turned in
numeric using the label and folder in
terms of training isolation forests and
the local life factor we're going to
split the test set and the training set
at 33% and if you look at the
setting the features I'm pretty much
using the default recommended features
number of estimators I'll talk about
what this parameter does number of
estimates is a hundred we will use in
this case because we have a label in in
the data set will use contamination rate
of 15% so much higher than the natural
rate of anomalies in this case and max
sample set 25 okay so it takes about 20
seconds to Train only as this is the SI
data set so this is a smaller one and
when a normalized States a local I fact
the training is faster but let's you
take a look at the results so I'm going
to show you the output of the of the
year
classification report as well as the
confusion matrix in terms of anomaly
detection what we are always interested
in is we are really interested in the
recall which is which is this upper
left-hand corner and you can see that
only trainings that this relation Forest
performs actually quite well and it gets
about 12 percent false positive right
I also calculate I you see also in this
case it may not always be relevant for
you and it's a pretty high I will see
the local knife factor on these dates
that doesn't do very well it only
achieves a recall rate of 8 and a half
percent and much higher false positive
rate so one more question so why is no
qualifier fact that doesn't do very well
perhaps it's the number of attributes in
this data set is quite a lot is 41 and
it may be it's just getting the
dimensionality Kherson here so let's
take a look at the SF data set some data
set has only four attributes and it's a
slightly bigger one in this case again
we are going to split test and reset
three percent and we're going to test a
solution force was exactly same
parameters take slightly longer to train
and the results are very similar to the
previous set so it's eves very high
recall which is exactly what we're
interested in and not a very high false
positive right I can look at the fact
that didn't do very well perhaps it's
the dataset itself
I've also tested it on non normalize
dataset the log of that factor and I
didn't see much difference so in this
case my well might say that you might
play with the number K which is which is
irrelevant
k nearest neighbor setting for local of
that factor in order to try to get a
perform better but this talk is not
about LOF so let's move on
it never performance on the test set
what is surprising is that isolation
forest does work pretty well and tested
as well so we have a 99% recall very
similar to the training set and a
hundred percent for the SF okay so now
let's talk about the estimators what I
find is that isolation forest is
actually very robust to parameter
setting and estimators will control how
many trees get built in the isolation
forest and we're going to see how
sensitive it is to this parameter for
the sake of this particular test I'm
turning my my scorer into a recall score
and I turned the minus 1 so the anomaly
into a positive label so we'll test the
performance on any where estimated so
number of trees in forests between 20 to
230 and what we see is that both recall
and I see a quite insensitive to this
and this actually matches to what the
original or
have published in their paper about the
algorithm being very robust after about
20 it achieves a very good recall mark
samples will control how much of the
data gets sampled to build the trees in
the other nation forest and the idea
here is that it's the sub sampling that
helps to explore these hidden layers or
subsets of the data so we'll look at the
performance of isolation forest always
max sample between 10% to going up to
100 so what we see is that it does serve
starts to suffer if you increase
sampling size and it is actually also
something that resonates back to the
original paper now the contamination
rate so if you choose to use a solution
forest as a supervised to classify it
was used the contamination rate as a
threshold to define on a set of all the
anomaly scores for all the data points
were to cut off in order to make it
anomaly versus not anomaly so this is
the parameter that the algorithm is
actually quite sensitive to and you can
see that we are going to test it for
anywhere between 1% so this is still
higher than the natural contamination
rate to 25 and after about 10 percent of
contamination it achieves a recall of
100
so we have looked at in terms of
parameterization so I said it's a it's
it's pretty robust to parameters and in
complexity it compares quite well
complexity to K K nearest neighbor and
other distance based or density based
algorithm so it's pretty you could say
that it's linear in its complexity so
let's go back to the topic of money
laundering I have said I started this
talk by saying what is an outlier what
is an anomaly but the truth is that most
of the automated money laundering
detection is actually not a simple
anomaly detection problem and it's not
really an outlier detection problem and
why is that well it's because many
hundreds of transactions that are
associated with money laundering they
differ very little from normal
transactions so as Liars are they are
hidden in the unusual behavior of low
dimensional subspaces and if you do
learn a second thing from this talk this
should be the one so I have put together
a data set which is well which is a
synthetic data set it's made up of fake
transactions but it has some money
laundering red flags embedded into it
the first Jupiter notebook is available
for you from my github page and I can
share with you the second Jupiter
notebook if you want to you can contact
me through my blog the link is at the
bottom so the idea here is that we we
have to take our clients transactions
and trades and we have to essentially
optimize it for a set of red flags the
red flags they are
they there are publications about them
your local financial financial crime
subject-matter experts will know more
about them but if you if you're
interested to read than consult
financial action task force website or
DFS or join my new learning group of
walls back row so I'm going to switch to
my synthetic data set and I'll talk
about it a little bit more the synthetic
data set is very small in this case it
has only 200 data points and I have
created four strategies in there and
first strategy the anomalies essentially
at five percent rate so what does it
look like it looks about like this what
we've put in the data point in in the
data set we have a client ID we have a
made-up security name it can be anything
a stock or bond or anything each client
in this case has ten transactions one
transaction per day we have a notional
amount which is purely random source
from uniform distribution we have a flag
for whether to buy or sell we have a
flag for whether this transaction is
followed by an asset transfer so if it's
a pile and it may be followed by an
asset transfer out if it's a sell it may
be followed by an asset transfer in
sorry preceded by a asset transfer in
and then there is some sort of currency
pay in this case were not looking at the
currency pair of the foreign exchange
type of strategy but this is a fake
currency pair in most cases and we also
have a flag for settlement to offshore
legal entity so most of you who work
with transactional data will already
immediately recognize that this is one
step or many a few steps after the raw
data set so in this case what I'm what
I'm kind of getting to is to the idea of
summarizing
no data for a specific type of off
anomaly over over at flag
so our niska's isolation force max
sample I'm setting to 50% because this
is a very small data set and what we're
going to do is we're just going to feed
the raw synthetic data into isolation
forests in this case and after doing
that we will compare what is the mean
anomaly score for those records that
were created to mimic a particular money
learning strategy versus those that
haven't and what we see here is not
isolation forest does managed to assign
a more negative score on average two
data points that were designed to mimic
money laundering visually this will look
like this
so these are the points this is the
first set of trades sorry this is the
first set of race so this is index 0 and
mirror out mirror Ian and then offshore
also isolation forest manages to get
quite a few false positive in this case
so let's go one step further we are now
going to actually do what we said we're
going to fold our data set and to
optimize it for looking for a particular
round flag in this case was trading I'm
not going to talk about what it is if
you want to know more about the
strategies talk to me after this call
after this presentation so we will
summarize activity as a ratio of bias
versus cells in the same security and
this is what gets fed into the pass
elation forest again was very much the
same the same parameter settings in this
case were not using contamination rate
this is not a supervised classification
problem and in my de said we only had
one one example which was a true
positive for sure and isolation forest
dust find this data point let's look at
another strategy as a transfer strategy
so if you go on a DFS website and search
for Mira we will find documents that are
specific to this this is a very well
known case and what we are looking for
we are looking for activity where which
is preceded or followed by as a
transpose this is what gets summarized I
folded into the summary and gets fed
into the isolation for us there were two
data points not two data points two
trading strategies at all 20/20 records
in a data set and they are index 1 and
the index
so again isolation forest does manage to
find it
so far I hope you understood that the
idea for using anomaly detection
algorithm is to be able to explore these
sub samples of a data set and another
extension to application to anomaly
detection would be to use what's called
a risk-based approach which is often
what the financial crime compliance
teams tend to do but the idea here is
that to actually focus on a particular
group of high-risk clients focus on
particular client network for example
all legal entities that share the same
beneficial owner or all legal entities
that actually share the same big code
and anything else and for the other so
and then the this this extra parameter
this extra feature will be then
introduced into the isolation forests so
in conclusion the anomalous activity in
AML is Bank type specific different
strategies are used for different types
of Bank isolation Forest is a promising
robust classifier that can be used for
in within the AML space the successful
automatic detection starts with asking
the right question and then optimizing
the data set for the data model that
that you want to construct thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
any questions thank you very much for
the presentation I'd be interested so an
isolation forest doesn't scale terribly
well typically doesn't do out of core so
I'd be interested if in the applications
you're interested in that's a challenge
both in terms of memory or in terms of
CPU usage so as I said the quite often
financial crab plants team they will
focus on a particular risk or group of
clients in order to do a risk based
approach that in itself minimizes the
type of Records you have to look through
and another thing is that unlike in prey
crowd for detection in my eulogy
detection we have a luxury of doing it
offline it doesn't have to be immediate
or as fast as possible it can take you
can take a few days or weeks in order to
do it offline
so typically the problem is the memory
usage so can I ask whether you're using
like hardware where the large large
amount of memory or not the reason I'm
asking is that people often tell us it's
too expensive to buy hardware with one
terabyte of RAM and then I get a fight
worthy where the person's like it's not
that expensive and I just can't do
isolation forest out of court
so do you run specific hardware or just
small computers
yeah and firstly I cannot us answer the
the specifications of the machine that
we use at the bank I didn't put it
together I know it's a supercomputer
yeah thanks to that you so initially you
showed really good recall it was sort of
in the demonstration really good recall
but quite poor LOF I'm not really
familiar with that we'll just have a
quick look now it's like presumably just
something for anomaly detection can you
just give some more intuition like why
do you think that is or because it
sounds like you're spreading quite a
wide net but then you're missing
possible anomalies so I don't know
that's what it seemed like maybe yeah
I'm not sure exactly why LOF didn't do
very well on this task I think it's just
this particular dataset it doesn't
perform very well I have seen very
similar performance of LOF on this data
set reported in other papers so I just
gave up and try to optimize it I think
it's the it's the fall of decay the
number of neighbors is very it's very
sensitive to that parameter and I think
that's probably where if you wanted to
optimize if you would you would play
with that parameter
Thanks would you be able to say anything
more about the metric which isolation
forest is using you mentioned about the
number of edges about the metrics about
the about the expectation number of
edges number of edges it's sorry if the
question it's not very clear the metric
question okay so what happens is that
isolation forest has two stages the
training stage and the testing stage in
the training stage it will build the
trees in the in the in the forest and in
the testing stage it will pass each data
point through each tree and it will code
it will record at what stage hits the
external load and then the number of
edges it has to travel through for each
tree gets averaged over and the shorter
is that traveling through for a data
point the more likely it is to be the
anomaly I hope their answers
thank you very much for the talk quick
question so because the datasets have
labels that you that you can use to
calculate recall and metrics how do you
apply that in practice when you don't
have the labels and how do you tune your
model since you can't you know calculate
recalling metrics yeah you're right in
practice we don't have labels and so
what we have in the financial Chrome
team we have analysts who the cases that
are seemed of interest they get followed
forwarded to and they essentially have
it's it's it's a humans looking at
transactions and trades and trying to
understand whether they are of interest
or not that's how it's used in practice
oh I think you mentioned that
false-positive rate is about 12% right
but in practice what can you do if you
have such a high positive false positive
rate I mean you probably get referred
such a large amount of cases and what
can you do how can you look through all
of that for young yeah it's actually a
false positive rate of 12% for AML is
actually very low most of the time most
of the time the false positive rate is
close to 100 so it's very promising
thank you
[Applause]